good morning and can i welcome you to
this meeting of mid-suffolk
uh district council development control
committee a
um first of all i just need to remind
you some of the direct domestic
arrangements for today
can i asks that when you please ensure
that microphones are muted and cameras
are turned off when you're not speaking
and please do not interrupt other
speakers when they are speaking
members are reminded not to use the
messaging or chat function during the
meetings
unless it is to report a pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest
or to notify myself that you wish to
make a proposal
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open
such as skype chat and that if you are
contacted by a third party during the
application
you should bring this to the attention
of the legal advisor who is with us
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting we may have to ask you to leave
additionally ask questions by myself
to the meeting please use the hands up
function
if you're experiencing poor connection
issues in the first instance please just
try turning off your camera
if this does not work please turn off
all incoming video
these options can be found on the three
little dots
which are part of the team's layout next
to the hand function on the information
bar
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be
capable of repeated viewing the whole of
the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
so i'd just like to do some
introductions as i said
we have ian de prez who is our legal
advisor with us
robert carmichael the governance officer
john pateman g the area planning manager
uh alex scott who is a case officer and
we will have some ward members
who at mississauga district council can
speak on an application
within their ward but may not vote on it
okay so can i move on to the agenda
please an agenda item number one uh i
will now ask the governance officer to
roll call for the members present please
thank you chair so if members could
please respond with the
either good morning or present so
councillor rachel ebern
present councillor john field
president councilman matthew hicks
present
counselor sarah mansell
present councillor john matheson
present counselor richard mayer
president councillor dave muller
present counselor tim passmore
and then for the ward members we have
councillor andrew mellon
present castle helen geek
and counselor sarah manso is already on
the committee so um
already noted thank you chair very much
um do we need to receive any decorations
of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members now
i'd just like to
i'm one is speaking on behalf of one of
the applica
applicants and obviously mr horn was a
district councillor
uh in in a previous administration so uh
there is just just to declare that i
think is
worth noting
any other declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
uh councilor matheson yeah i've advised
officers
um of a non-pecuniary interest regarding
the
um elmsweil application
just for the record um
good morning um chairman uh counselors
this is the legal advisory in the page
is to say councilman matheson has indeed
made me and the monetary officer known
uh
this matter known to us and he sees it
is
the monetary officer and i agree it's a
non-pecuniary interest based on old
um acquaintanceship and and um
friendship
which is no more than a non-pecuniary
interest that's properly declared as
such
okay and why are there mr duprez
obviously uh
just mr horn was a district council says
uh
familiar to many of us is that uh is
that worth noting
worth noting that i i dare say um
oh he he didn't seek re-election did he
a year ago so the newer members of the
committee won't have known him
regardless of political affiliation but
some of the long-standing members will
have known him indeed and that's that
can be noted thank you
okay thank you very much um any other
declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
nope okay thank you uh agenda might
agenda item number three is decorations
of lobbying
um are there any to declare now i
suspect
we've all um had the same ones but let's
start uh
with the order of the hands up and just
see
first up is uh councillor mansell
uh hello uh yes i have been
lobbied on the elmswell um application
i've been contacted
by both the applicant and the objector
uh thank you uh councillor matheson
microphone i've been lobbied regarding
the
um elmsworld application also
thank you and counselor e burn um now
elsewhere one but i said i thought we
all worked it went to
the planning committee but um the amsoil
application thank you yeah i was just
going to say we've all had a
uh an email has gone to all members of
the committee uh regarding hedgerows and
elmswear
so um i think that's noted for all of us
okay any anything else on that front
that anyone wishes to
declare regarding lobbying nope okay
thank you very much uh agenda item
number four is declarations of personal
site visits
do we have any uh council mansell
ah thank you chair uh yes i i
i did make a um cycle ride
past the application in wyverston uh the
other day to go look at
where it was uh and just to put the
record straight
the site in elmswell is about 400 meters
from where i live and i probably pass it
at least three times a week
okay thank you that's noted any other
personal site visits
nope okay thank you uh next agenda item
number four is confirmation the minutes
of the meeting that were held on the
22nd of july
um are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes that start on
page seven of our papers
and run through to page 11.
nope okay uh can i have a proposal
uh that we accept the minutes please
thank you uh
uh it was proposed by i'll just do it in
the order the hands went up proposed by
councillor muller seconded by council
matheson uh can the governance officer
therefore please now take a roll call
vote
i think sorry about that so um
if you please respond with for against
or abstain
so councillor rachel ebern
abstain i wasn't there thanks thank you
counselor john field
sure councillor matthew hicks four
councillor sarah mansell
four councillor john matherson
for councillor richard mayer
four councillor dave miller
or and cancer tim passmore
uh abstention because i wasn't on the
committee at the time thank you council
thank you chair that is carried
lovely thank you members thank you yes
sorry rick mayor here
um apologies i should have um declared a
site visit to the wiveston
um okay thank you thank you for
notifying us that we'll put on the
record
thank you okay so the minutes the
meeting have now been confirmed and we
will get them signed at the next
practical
opportunity okay thank you for that
agenda item number six is to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition
scheme do we have any please none
received here
thank you very much okay we now move on
to the schedule of planning applications
and tend to stay in the order in which
they are in the papers
the first application before us is dc 19
dash 876 hedgerows grove lane elmswell
and i will invite the case officer john
papendry to please introduce the
application to the committee
morning just bear with me
this is all freezing up now this is
always good timing i'll give you a bear
with me one moment
so can you see i'm sharing that's great
okay
we can but it's not in presentation mode
it's in uh yeah
i can't it's just
there you go there you go perfect right
uh oh so hang on one moment
this is freezing
i've just realized something just bear
with me one moment i apologize for this
why is it not doing that
can you just give me one moment i'm just
trying to reset it and start again
right let's try that again let's go back
in there
right okay so that's still not changed
see ah sees have a massive delay i do
apologize members i don't know if that's
coming across in any other way hopefully
you can now see this powerpoint
presentation so this is
uh application dc 19 of 1876
hedgerows grove lane elmswell
this is an application with all matters
reserved
except for access this is application
for the erection of two detached
bungalows
and a vehicular access so this
application sets the number
your single story but appearance
and as well as the access but appearance
layout landscaping scale
our reserve matters are not part of this
application before us today
the site is north of elmswell it's a
very sustainable location
uh with a range of services within the
settlement itself
the site is off grove lane um if you can
see
my cursor we have ashfield road going
out from the north of elmswell and this
is grove lane
coming across here
the site is just in here
it is beyond the settlement boundary it
is countryside in planning terms
and via the local plan but it has no
other designations
um this by the way is an airfield i
believe
closer in mangrove lane and we find the
site itself
his head revolves just on the left here
as his half acre a modest cottage on the
on the right
on the opposite side of the road we have
a grove farm which is a listed
two-story property hedgerows itself is a
bungalow
so the official site in red and
other ownership is in blue which is this
l-shaped piece of land here and the
squarish piece of land here
this is hedgerows itself
and the listed building is just shown on
this constraints map
on the opposite side of the road
so the site is set back from the road
essentially behind hedgerows and behind
the planning permission dc
1802 553 so
that earlier permission for outline was
granted for two bungalows
within this area here oh sorry it's gone
back one
within this area here site is behind
that one
so essentially uh if we were to approve
two bungalows in this area
in total in this whole site
the access which is part of this
application
was also part of the application for
this outline
and was granted that includes the
visibility displays associated with that
access and it would include the removal
in part
of some of the vegetation along the
frontage of this site
for the avoidance of doubt the site we
are considering before us
is agricultural land
there are a number of public rights away
in the area these are shown on this
planet
in a red dotted line um and the
settlement boundary of elmsworth is
shown
in this blue line here
the public footpaths the network in
various places there may be more
actually beyond the ones i'm just
showing but i was just showing the ones
between elmswell and
the site itself these are
not lit and it is agreed that they may
be unsuitable in wintertime
it is not envisaged these roots would be
the main choice of travel compared to a
car but they are available as a choice
as they were for the two bungalows
already approved
so the group of dwellings that we're
looking at
for a kilometer away from the settlement
boundary bar
or just under a kilometer it will
um services within the settlement itself
range from different distances so they
are obviously further than a kilometer
away
as for noting as well we have various
existing
pockets of development along ashfield
road
uh oakland and so on we also have
permission for more housing
to infill along ashfield road
so the site itself is a
agricultural field
and well enclosed and all this is the
frontage of the sights
um in different seasons obviously that
would look different
um third parties have mentioned the
former medieval green and historic
landscape
and it is mentioned documents such as
the heritage and settlement sensitivity
assessment for beiber and it's like
district councils which is march 2018
which is an evidence document for the
emerging local plan
the area the green used to cover is on
screen
section 8 of my report covers this
particular point in detail
it was not a consideration had led to
direct refusals of applications on its
own
including the font bungalows approved in
august 2018
but it was a matter that has been
considered as part of a refusal to the
setting of a list of buildings in one
known case
however in that case which was for
dagwood farm
it was confirmed that the green is not
regarded as a non-designated
asset
so to conclude policies sometimes
cs5 from cs1 and 2 h7
are upheld as out of date against the
nppf
regardless of council having a five-year
housing supply
the wall pit appeal and others since
have established this
and so full weight cannot be given to
these policies
with consideration of policies such as
h13 h15 gp1
h16 and various elements of the nppf
the proposal is a small enclosed pocket
of existing and improved
development identifiable as not being an
open countryside
it is a very small scale development
both in number and density
and nature being single story single
story would be in keeping with hedgerows
and the two bungalows already approved
on the frontage of the site
there will be the removal of some
vegetation along the frontage
but it is considered material that this
authority has already approved this
removal
via the previous application for the
same access
the extensive landscape finishes are a
benefit and allow this site to be
non-intrusive to the wider open
countryside
and contained between the two existing
dwellings and form a cluster
with the already approved bungalows the
recommendation is one of approval
and with conditions including conditions
for biodiversity
and renewable energy integration
thank you
thank you um a couple of questions can
you just
we've all received an email uh regarding
the judicial review
yes okay and uh we've been told there
are five
separate grounds for a refusal i believe
all five separate grounds have been
looked at
can we just talk us through the
relevance of that to
what's before us now and and how we have
to what wait or if any we have to give
that
um so this application has been with us
for a little while on the basis that it
was first determined
um a little while ago um and it was
delegated as approval
unfortunately it was realized that the
case officer at the time
had not put the site notice up at the
right time and therefore the site notice
hadn't
expired when that decision was made
so therefore uh it went through the
judicial review process
and was effectively made live again
because it was obviously prejudicial to
other people
have not having the chance to reply and
make representation because the site
notice had
not expired yet that of all the other
grounds that i mentioned there was the
only one that was the judicial review
it was predicated on so
that setting to one side um was
the issue dealt with then and it doesn't
make it has no bearing
on the material considerations of the
application before members today
okay so the only consideration for us
is that the fact that the application uh
it was ineffectively was not timed
correctly in terms of the site notice
therefore the application
has been resubmitted in effect in effect
so the the decision was squashed
um and therefore it becomes a live
application again
and therefore we've obviously you know
taken
more time and we have agreed as part of
that process to present it to committee
to ensure that it's an
open and transparent process that is why
it's before
members i should have said that at the
beginning i do apologize um because
obviously normally an application like
this would not be
uh before members um unless called in by
members
um so ultimately that is where we are
here i don't know if
our indie prey wishes to comment any
further but
mr president i don't need to add much
chairman john has said
most of what's necessary that i i don't
if there may have been a recent email
just to members
i hadn't seen i don't need to hold
things up by saying i want to read it
this minute
if that's the case but yeah there was
that there was a delegated decision
under delegated powers
that unfortunately as john has said
there was a procedural error
an undeniable procedural error there was
a judicial review brought on five
grounds
um first basically the judicial review
was com as it
often often happens there's the judicial
review was compromised by consent order
the one ground where the council had to
acknowledge there was an undeniable
error
um was was the the um the fact that the
making this decision too soon in in
putting it in
through plain english the there were
four other grounds of
challenge that broadly speaking can be
characterized as the claimant saying
even if it was in time i still think
it's a legally wrong decision
and in what that often happens the
consent order basically said they don't
need to be determined
now um the sometimes the party insists
on taking a case to court because they
want to argue those points but that
didn't happen
uh often the court time doesn't need to
be taken up
where there is an agreement on one
essential
reserve their position for later if
necessary
and the um those are matters for
but yes it's being presented to you as a
new application so the the
the the um decision that's been
um quashed is has gone
and we're back to square one as it were
so i think i think that hopefully that
makes things clear okay thank you and
i'm just sorry if i can
uh just there no other hands up so i'll
just keep asking some questions i've got
so
the entrance to the site um has
already been determined by the fact that
there are two bungalows with permission
granted on the right-hand side between
uh which you talked about earlier so
does that mean
actually we there's nothing we can do in
terms of the entrance and the access
because that's predetermined
i want no no no i want to be very
careful here um that's why i'm trying to
clarify the application before you
includes access
so it is to be judged on its individual
merits
as an access um and as part of the
application before you
it is not a reserve matter so you are
considering access as part of the debate
today
um however i would uh
recommend that members do consider the
previous approval which has an access in
the precise home location
and with the same visibility displays as
a material consideration
to be given significant weight uh
the best that that has moved in that
location
and is approved for uh the visibility
displays
um that will remove vegetation
as necessary so you know bear in mind
then that
you know if reserve matters came forward
with the other application
and were approved they could go ahead
and do the works and the access
um as as we've eventually got in front
of us but we need to be very careful
it is it is a separate application um
this is a
proposal and it does need to be judged
on its own merits as well
but i would say that there is a material
wait with the other
application to be considered thank you
that's very helpful
okay uh counselor matheson
thank you uh two questions
firstly um can you
show us and and tell us the width of the
road
um grove lane and second
question can you tell us about the age
of
the um the pasture the grassland
um which the site comprises
the answer we know for both of those um
i can show you grove lane
uh but i i don't have the ability to
measure it accurately because it's a
rural lane
which has vary in whips all the way
along it and it has various
differences in highway verge so to take
a specific point along there would be
inappropriate and unreasonable to do so
in terms of the pasture land
i have no idea how old
that area is it could be yesterday
that grass grew on it it could be how
where do we where are we taking age form
in terms of its existence in terms of
boundaries
i i don't know so i i can't answer that
either
it is indeed part of the former medieval
green
um which is many hundreds of years old
um
and um you know that's uh i think i've
put that in
the report on section eight uh that
talks about it
i think there was a date there but i
can't get back to my report to look at
it for the moment
um but the you know so i i would have no
doubt that there is
we're not denying there is historic
landscape uh in the context of the
the site um and that that's uh before
the record
thank you yeah i was asking more in
terms of biodiversity than
i mean i quite agree that the um the
medieval green argument and i used to
live on it
as um it doesn't hold much water at all
can i just say john that's expressing an
opinion at this stage we're only asking
points of clarity
no we're not in debate please have you
got any other questions john
sorry miss councillor matheson no those
were the two
thank you thank you councilman
well thank you chair and thank you john
for that um presentation
um i've got two questions if i may could
you tell me the distance
from the site to the co-op um in the
center of
elm soil please and secondly um
could you tell me how far
along the road or show me on a on a map
so if someone would say walking in
winter
to the co-op how far they'd have to walk
before they get to
a um footwear a paved footway or
effectively where does the paved footway
start it
in elmsville thank you
um right i can't measure while i'm in
presentation mode i'd have to
switch over um because unfortunately we
don't have paper anymore so i can't sit
and
measure that but i can i can do that
offline in a moment and come back to you
on that one
would you just while you're on that map
would you be able to point
up here it's just a bit further south i
think
because you've got the railway and i
thought there was a
convenience store in here somewhere yeah
and the co-op's just
the south side of the railway okay
okay um so in terms of
um paved uh he's paved to roughly about
this point here
i don't believe it's paved beyond there
and it is not paved along grove lane
itself okay thank you
thank you very much uh councillor muller
uh thank you chair um council rebounds
actually just asked the question i was
going to ask a
chair thank you from councillor mayor
thank you john can you um
comment on the parish council's
position that reliance on the concept of
tilted balance is
insupportable as the development plan is
clearly breached
okay
so we have uh the the local plan um
and we it is considered to be out of
date in the context
of the nppf so we've got the local plan
1998 and we have other documents that
came
before the nppf which was 2012 onwards
um and we look at the the mppf we it
essentially says if you don't have an
update local plan um
it is not full weight now this was
was tried and terror the war pit appeal
uh that we
we all know um and
from that point onwards it's been very
clearly established that we have
the other half today and therefore
should be given less weight
and that includes uh the housing supply
policies
um of the council and tomorrow
so as we're deemed to be out of weight
date
um we do we and we have a five-year hand
supply now yeah we used to be out of
date we didn't have a
five year housing supply uh we do have a
housing supply but we you know so we
have more weight that we can give to our
local
uh plan policies but we can't give them
absolute weight
on the basis that they're still out of
date by the nppf
therefore there is a tilde balance in
respect of
um in favor of sustainable development
and that is the debate that you are as
members
uh needing to grapple with in terms of
you know is this sustainable
and does it cause demonstrous harm
um and i that that's where we in this
summary
it's very hard to summarize all of that
in a very quick way
uh is the position we have i appreciate
the parish council
feel that the neighbor the local plan
should be given far more weight
and the development plan is given weight
uh but um it is a judgment of how much
weight to give it
um by being out of debt it is the
discretion of members how much weight
they give the
their local plan in context with the
nppf
but um we don't advise to give it full
weight
on the basis of our composition and the
age of it
lovely thank you thank you very much uh
cancer mansell
uh thank you chair um if i may i could
answer counselor e burns questions
about the distances uh
well have you had i i know what they are
because i've measured them in advance of
the meeting
okay um it is 1.8 kilometers from the
site
to elmsworld co-op and you give that in
miles for those that are involved
1.6 kilometers is a mile so it's about a
mile and a bit
um and it is 800 meters to the start of
the pavement
which starts at the um junction of oak
lane
and rashfield road so the footpath that
is marked as a
red dotted line on the current
presentation comes out
onto ashfield road a little bit way
north of oakland
so there is a little bit of road without
a pavement even if you go on the
footpath through
okay thank you for that very useful
thank you
okay any other questions for points of
clarity at this point before we move on
nope okay so we now move on to the
public speakers
uh we have mr peter dao from the parish
council uh we do ask you to keep to
three minutes please
um and if you'd like to turn your camera
on and your microphone on
do you want to close the presentation
without yeah
if i can mr dao
if you could turn your am i with you
yep there that's good okay and uh we'll
just make sure everyone
if you'd like to start and when you
start you have up to three minutes
thank you john if you can just go to
mute
yeah sorry
okay mr daryl when you're ready thank
you uh
the judicial review allows what elmsell
parish council considers to be a welcome
pause
it's accepted by your officers as a new
application
and they went back to square one it also
gives a very detailed analysis of the
basis of the officer's decision
it clearly identifies the shortcomings
in the reasoning
that inform that decision and elmsl
parish council welcomes the chance
of a more mature and informed view from
members
rather than that of a single original
case officer
the conclusions reached vindicate what
else apparently council
and many others have argued time and
time again
in attempting to have proper weight
accorded to local development plan
policies
the blanket assumption within the
approval decision was that the
authority's development plan policies
are out of date
and we've just heard that they can be
given either more weight
or absolute weight and this is down to
the judgment
of members there is no dispute
that the application site is in the
countryside there is no dispute
but the application site is not
cartilage but agricultural land
there is no dispute as members will know
that the road giving immediate access is
a single track lane
with passing places serving the
industrial estate
which houses hd wilson's giant lorries
under their hgv operators there is no
dispute
the pedestrian access beyond grove lane
towards the village
is a long and fast and busy active road
with no pavement until the outskirts of
the village of reach
and there's no dispute the pedestrian
route is far longer than that suggested
in the original officers report
and councilor mansell has addressed this
there is furthermore no dispute
that the historical dimension of this
landscape on the ancient buttonhole
green must suffer
if this development requires more loss
of mature hedgerow
which you may decide it might well do
what amazon parish council does dispute
is the office's contention
that the tilted violence test within
nppf
need to take no account of the
undisputed negatives i've just listed
these are set against the annoyingly
ill-considered suggestion
that another two car-bound dwellings in
our countryside
will support the vitality and viability
of our village
our well-documented vitality and our
proven vibrancy are well supported and
in the process of being well augmented
by virtue of a 47 uplifting housing
stock
already on the way in short this
proposal
is yet another imposition on our
freed from the wrongful assertions and
assumptions of the original officers
report
we asked members to refuse this
application
as a postscript it is suggested that
the previous lack of perspective and
poor practice has already cost the
authority nine and a half thousand
pounds
plus its own considerable costs members
if not fully convinced that refusal is
right on a double or quick
basis could refuse permission and should
the applicant strive to appeal
allow an inspector the chance to make
what would be for our communities
and historic ruling thank you chairman
thank you very much uh mr dao do we have
any questions
for mr dao please or the parish
government i have a yes
order if i may yes of course um
in respect of the report the original
case officer was not myself
and the report was dealt with at the
time
he's not the report before members today
so
any issues in respect to the original
case officers report
are not part of the discussion and not
part of the debate
ultimately your members are to consider
the recommendation of officers before
you today
which is what is in your papers and i
just want to make sure that's very clear
okay uh thank you chair
uh mr dao um question you mentioned the
industrial state at the end of grove
lane
uh how many movements approximately each
day are they with these hgv vehicles
going down and back and forth on a grove
lane please
we don't have a traffic count on grove
lane
but as councillor mansell as a close
neighbor will confirm
it is many many dozens of movements
and i think a very important point is
the size
of the vehicles that are using that uh
i've been at several site meetings with
members
where they've been very aware of the
size of
hc wilson's 20 rear steer
super lorries and they have to go in and
out
every day for hc wilson to operate
thank you mr dan thank you mr uh
castlefield
just just a quick check mr dow
referred to a single track road
which presumably supports all these
massive lorries
is that the road i saw a photograph of
during the
presentation because the photograph
seemed to show
something which was uh one heck of a lot
wider than the village road i'm sitting
next to at the moment it seemed to be
anything but single john can you just
confirm
yes so uh john pemg can you just confirm
the picture you put up was that the same
road
that is grove lane yes yes thank you
grove lane is a two-way vote
it's a rural road and i
you know two lorries going past each
other might have difficulties
along with parts of it but um certainly
at the point of the access for this site
is clearly too
lame okay so it's a varying road in
width as you go along it
okay yeah it is you know uh uh possibly
people will be criticized by saying it's
too late
you know it does vary it's a vulnerable
road with different characteristics
so it varies along the width of the road
okay thank you
thank you does that answer your question
council field
well sort of sort of i see mr dale
shaking his head
but uh it does seem to be physically uh
a lot wider so i think that the thing is
it varies in parts
okay any other questions for the parish
council no
okay thank you very much mr dan thank
you for joining us today
um okay so we'll now move on uh we now
have the opportunity to
ask an objector to speak i have
rob sherwood and ellen whitchurch who
would like to speak
if you turn your cameras on and your
microphones
please
thank you and welcome and again you have
up to three minutes
uh good morning chairman and committee
members i'm rob sherwood
i live next door to hedgerows at half
acre i
came to live here with my family in 1954
aged seven and i returned to live here
nearly 20 years ago
by childhood memory of this field
periodically
blissfully grazed by a mixture of dairy
cows
uh more recently horses were kept in the
field
i appreciate there is a real need for
more housing
good housing everywhere in mid-suffolk
has now secured its five-year housing
land supply
and it seems that elmsville has already
made a substantial contribution to this
objective
so additional proposals for housing
contrary to the development plan
must be given very careful consideration
rather than pursuing
an automatic presumption in favor of
development
when the planning department granted
permission for the first two bungalows
on part of the field
fronting grove lane i believe they were
misguided and that the site was
incorrectly described as garden
the designated lawful agricultural use
wasn't tensioned
and there was no recognition of its
character it's part in the historic
landscape or even it's true distant from
the village facilities
the application before you now relates
to a part of the field further away from
the road
i would not wish the misunderstandings
that may have led to the first
application being approved
to be repeated compounding the error
i greatly appreciate that this new
report has responded
in more detail to many of my objections
i would like
these to be considered along with all
the other issues including
the loss of possibly the last hedged
feudal field in the length of grove lane
the further loss of visual character
and protected natural habitat of the
enclosed pasture
the further erosion of our connection to
remnants of the local historic landscape
and buttonhole green
the very limited economic social or
environmental benefits to the village
the poor sustainability of two more
homes with different
difficult access to village facilities
without using a car
and recognize again giving greater
weight to the opinions of those who
understand
and value the local area for example the
elder parish council
and the suffolk preservation society i
believe
that it is not appropriate to develop
this fight and i hoped after balancing
all the issues
you will reach the same view if however
at the end of your considerations you
are minded to grab
christian ask that you mitigate its
impact
in some way by applying suitable
conditions
this would ensure that this unique site
is at least an exemplary development of
eco design principles
for example as could be achieved by a
passive house plus specification
which could plot in net zero energy
living
and with the buildings sympathetically
integrated into the natural landscape
thank you mr sherwood thank you okay
thank you do we have any questions
yeah madison and councillor field
yeah thank you could you help us on the
question that i asked earlier regarding
the age of the pasture
in in your knowledge
well in my knowledge it has always been
pasture um obviously i've not been here
every day the last since
i uh first here in 1954 but
the rush the farmers who
were here quite a while before we moved
here
um they always had it in their grazing
rotation
um for as long as they were here so
it's probably been uncultivated
for hundreds of years i've no proof of
that um
but i have no reason to believe anything
other than that
thank you very much field
thank you uh mr sherwood uh we we've had
much of the
distance to the amenities in elmswell
uh since your neighbour i wonder could i
just ask
is it possible to use sustainable means
to get to those
um amenities do you walk or cycle or do
you use a car
or worse well um
i have to say i always use my car
i i do have a walking problem i had a
spinal fracture
um quite a few years ago and this
made it impossible for me to use
footpaths without a great deal of pain
and um obviously i'm a bit wobbly on my
feet
it it groveling is a dangerous road i
mean i have to say
and i know one other person i won't name
them
who like myself was walking in grove
lane
and was actually my jacket was brushed
by a passing commercial vehicle this was
a few years ago
some of the drivers are very considerate
but there are quite a few
um who do not respect the speed limit
and they do not seem to respect the fact
it's a narrow country lane
okay thank you so thank you
okay um any other questions at all for
mr sherwood nope okay thank you very
much for joining us
can i can i make the point about the
vehicles
no i'm sorry you you cannot no i'm sorry
you don't get an opportunity to come
back i'm sorry
okay i don't know thank you
um okay so next we moved uh we now uh
we don't have a supporter uh who would
like to speak we do have the applicant
who would like to speak
uh david barker so mr buck if you could
please turn on your microphone and your
camera
and again you have three minutes to
address the committee
hello can you hear me okay we can be uh
thank you thank you thank you good
morning um
we proposed bungalows because they're a
house tie needed locally and because
this reduces the impact on the
neighbours in the surrounding area
bangalores are rarely provided on larger
developments
the vehicular access has been kept to a
single access in the center of our
client's property
so it's not on the boundary with the
neighbor where it could cause them
disturbance or affect the boundary trees
my client's family lives in will my
office and home are in the same area
the thurston elmsworld wall pit and
hawley area is a sustainable one
with a great many facilities that serve
almost all day-to-day needs
the application site is well placed in
this area and so is more sustainable
than much of the wider district of
mid-suffolk
on a very nearby site with the same
policy considerations
at the junction of grove lane and
ashfield road seven homes have been
approved locally under appeal
including one less than a year ago our
site is better screened and less
prominent than the nearby site for seven
homes
our clients have approval for two
bungalows on the frontage of their
product
this creates a good precedent for the
two bungalows in this application
an application of reserve matters for
the bungalows on the front
and in this application will be designed
together so they can come forward as a
comprehensive development
there are no objections from
professional consultees including
highways officers
i know graveland well and it can easily
accommodate the local traffic that uses
it
we'll be happy to have a condition that
all construction vehicles must park off
the road
this application has been a long
expensive process for the council
council's legal advice about planning
barrister was that the judicial review
could be defended
because the application had been
advertised in several ways not just by
the disputed scientists
the council had widely publicized the
application including writing to
neighbours
the judicial review was brought because
the second site notice was put up
and the application was approved before
the date for consultation comments
expired
our client has tried to work with the
objection
several times the objective property is
only a small common boundary with the
application side of a meter or so
the object to raise concerns about the
common boundary and we're happy to keep
the trees in the hedge on that boundary
as well as on the northern and western
boundaries the site is very well
enclosed by mature hedges as
is within a cluster of homes to the east
and south
the neighbor has discussed with our
client they want to develop an eco home
on their property and want
our client to do the same this
application is an outline and
sustainability measures would normally
be put forward at the reserve matters
stage
there are several planning conditions
proposing the committee report that
includes sustainability measures
and we support these this application
and other developments nearby have been
consistently supported by district and
county councils
or allowed appeal this proposal will
cause minimal impact on the surrounding
area because of the hedge screening
will meet a need for bungalows and is
more sustainably located than much of
the housing in the district it will
provide economic benefits to local
builders
and i hope that you'll be able to
support the application thank you
thank you very much
nope okay thank you very much for
joining us thank you
okay i'll now ask the ward members uh we
have two board members councillor
mansell and councillor
who would like to go first we're in your
hands
i'd like to give first chair if that's
okay yep of course
right thank you um there are many
grounds for refusing this application
but i'm going to concentrate on heritage
so that's the green and the listed
building
firstly the green i don't want to give
you a lecture on the importance of
buttonhole green but i do have to point
out a few things to show you how
important it
is a green as you all know is an area of
common land that dates back to medieval
or even earlier times
used in the past by all common rights
holders for grazing
now farmers tended to live around the
edges of greens so that they had easy
access to both their arable fields
and the common grazing land commons and
common age settlement
are very characteristic of mid-suffolk
and that's in contrast to the nucleated
villages you tend to find elsewhere and
that's because medieval suffolk farmers
tend to be free
men in other places you get powerful
lords who build planned villages of
surfs where people could easily be
controlled and made to work on the
lord's farm
in suffolk medieval farmers were
strongly individual and entrepreneurial
they would they would band together when
necessary but they normally worked alone
now buttonhole green the green we're
dealing with here is one of the oldest
and largest greens or commons in suffolk
it was such a
crucial communal resource that as many
as four parishes claim to share in it
and it's also one of the best preserved
greens we have left particularly here in
its northern half
now because of the scale of development
to the south this area to the north of
elmswell where all those four parishes
meet
becomes even more valuable in heritage
and landscape terms and so
shouldn't be lost now the feeling of the
open landscape
may not be a material consideration but
the heritage value should be
grove farm and half acre they provide
what you might call a visible
demarcation
of the edge of the former green in this
area and this development will
cause harm to this it's the edge of the
common that's the important thing
now the second heritage consideration is
the impact on the nearby listed building
the heritage team did not comment on the
impact on the setting of the grade two
listed grove farm
either for this application or for the
previous application for the two
bungalows fronting onto grove lane
now this is a serious emission grave
grove farm is a listed 16th century
common edge farmhouse its setting is the
common
for which it forms the edge and it is
only just across the road
so that this proposed development site
forms a really important part of the
understanding
of the medieval and the early
post-medieval setting of the farmhouse
so surely the harm resulting from this
development should have been assessed
and i would think it would be sensible
to ask the heritage team to give an
opinion
given that mid-suffolk's development
control committees have a
track record of refusing planning
permission for developments which affect
the setting of nearby common edge listed
buildings
now examples just in the last year and
just in my ward
include those three houses near dagwood
farm also on the edge of buttonhole
green
and a single house near abbey cottage on
woolpit green
and that's perhaps the most similar
similar application to hedgerows
because it was again right next to a
group of two houses on the road
that had very recently been granted
planning permission
now both the abbey cottage and the
buttonhole sorry the abbey cottage and
the dagwood farm
um applications in both cases those
those refusals were upheld
on appeal by a planning inspector the
heritage response to the dagwood farm
appeal is really excellent and i would
recommend committee members that you
have a look at it before you
are vote in favor of allowing this
application
the only reason i can imagine that no
one's commented on the relationship
between grove farm and this development
is that there's an enormous lay landi
hedge around grove farm
it prevents the easy assessment of its
setting as a common edge farm
this hedge is completely out of keeping
of the surrounding landscape but of
course it's not permanent if it were to
be cut down
that link between grove farm and its and
the common at its common would return
but if the common edge is built over the
link will be permanently broken
now lastly there's the contention that
all our policies are out of date
that's apparently supported by several
appeal decisions but it's a pity that
the committee reporters
cherry-picked only those appeal
decisions which support its
recommendation
there are plenty of other appeal
decisions which tell a different story
and again just one from my ward from
this year
is lawn farm wool pit a very similar
situation on the edge of a common this
time will
heath a much less important common uh
the inspector said these policies are of
some age
and are to a degree inconsistent with
the framework the nppf
and so are afforded reduced weight in my
assessment
as reduced weight not no weight but that
reduced weight given to those policies
just 10 months ago
balanced with the heritage harms meant
that that appeal was dismissed
so houses were not built at lawn farm
and houses
should not be built here where the
common is both
more important and better preserved so
that's the end of my five minutes if i
could answer
counselor matheson's question about the
age of the
um of the grassland um if
mr sherwood is correct in thinking that
it's been
unplowed since 1954 it's very likely
that it has
has never been plowed um not since the
bronze age
um the common was enclosed in 1814 so it
may have been plowed that year
because there was a kind of arable
maximum during the napoleonic wars but
ever since then
uh everything we know about the
agricultural history of suffolk suggests
that it's very unlikely
thank you very much any questions for
councillor geek
no uh yes cancer field
yes just ask about the the the boundary
to the common uh you mentioned a very
large
layer andy hedge which is as you point
out
temporary but there is planning
permission for two
two bungalows i think yeah between the
road farm and uh common is
that we do aerial photograph help
that is true uh the application
the committee report for that um
committee
also didn't consider the impact on grove
farm which was you know
very uh easily arguable uh a big mistake
um but as i say there are uh there are
um comparable cases such as
um the land and will pick green abbey
cottage and will pick green
where um the uh the final um
the the the roadside uh houses have been
given permission but the committee then
uh
looked at that decision in in the round
and said well
that looking at the merits of this
decision on its own
um the the the perhaps it was a mistake
okay what i'm going to do is i if i i
don't think
it was necessarily used but you know you
have to be quite careful
you've made you've made quite a strong
statement that that that there was a
huge
i've lost you i think we need to be
quite careful here you've made quite a
strong
accuser obviously that there was a big
error that the listed building wasn't
taken
into account in the previous application
or on this one that's quite a strong
position to take and i think we need to
hear from the officers around whether
that has or has not happened
okay so it is the choice of the planning
officers when they consult
the heritage team and the heritage team
actually also have a
trade triage process when they don't
wish to comment on applications
in this case we have a listed building
which is this building just here
it is a reasonable distance away and it
has lots of
things in between we've got a pond we've
got other buildings and we have got
various vegetation along the road on
both this side of the road
and on this side of the road before we
get to
the site at the back here we also have
the consideration that we have got
two bungalows essentially approved in
front of it
if they were to go forward so no
the officer has not consulted the
heritage team
on this particular case dagworth farm
um has been mentioned in the report for
the specific reason that that was
mentioned by the representations
received
we didn't need to go further than that
we didn't think it was appropriate to
try and look at every list of building
on the entire common
uh because that'd be quite a few
ultimately though we did pick that one
up because that one was
refused by the council on the basis of
the common land
and was also refused by the heritage
team the reason for that is because
all the buildings associated with that
were listed buildings
we don't have a list of building
associated with the actual site
in this case but we did in that case and
it was very carefully construed
obviously those listed buildings were
set back
to the common land and the green in
front of them
the argument although unfortunately
the impils inspector did not agree with
that argument because they did not agree
that the common land was a
non-designated
uh asset in historic terms
they did agree though in terms of the
harm to the listed building
and that was a different issue so there
is
but you can see the relationship and of
course of members need to make that
judgment
in there i think that that was going to
be my point that's members can now make
the decision
on whether they think uh councillor geek
or john patman g is presenting
the appropriate uh position okay
any other questions for councillor geek
chancellor field then councillor ebern
sorry councillor field just has his hand
up still
an old hand i think we say uh
counselling indeed
sorry gentlemen counseling thank you
chair but
i was going to ask why there wasn't a
heritage um
statement in the pack from the heritage
officer given that the
cartilage of the listed building is
directly opposite
the site um because i've i've found that
but that's been answered that's been
covered yeah thanks any anyone else wish
to come in with any other questions
okay thanks very much um next we move to
councillor mansell
over to you is the other ward member uh
thank you chair um right uh firstly
i'd like to just remind everybody that
the previous
delegated decision to grant me um
needs to be disregarded since it was
quashed by the judicial review
so i i would urge you just to make your
own minds up without prejudice
um councillor geek has uh gone through
many heritage reasons for this
application being refusable
uh we at mid suffolk do not currently
have a local list of undesignated
ancient greens which has been mentioned
by the heritage officers
but but now green will hopefully be
listed as such
in the emerging elsewhere neighborhood
plan
um i cannot support this application for
two more bungalows in what i believe
is an unsustainable location just
because regrettably permission was
granted for the two bungalows in front
of this plot does not mean that it is
suitable for a development of what will
um now be four new dwellings
uh placing these two dwellings behind
the line of existing dwellings along
that side of grove lane would also be
contrary to the pattern of development
along this part of the lane the officer
report talks about walking distance to
the amenities in the village
but this is extremely misleading the map
on page
23 of your report shows clearly the
possible routes
to the settlement boundary not to the
amenities
which are much further away the ration
the co-op
and the closest service bus stop are all
about 1.8
kilometers away the primary school 2.2
kilometers
and the church of england church 2.7
kilometers
the first 800 meters of all of these
journeys
is either along a road without a
pavement or across rough
footpaths which will become very muddy
in wet
i know about the footpaths i run on them
regularly um
and do get extremely mild and slippery
grove lane which is the accent
for extra large hgvs of h.g wilson
is a single track road with passing
places
yes heard that it has varying width
and the photograph which was shown as
part of the
presentation is a google street map
picture which has
got a very wide angle lens so i don't
think you can really judge the width of
the lane
uh it is uh probably in between
this plot and ashfield road i would say
it is wide enough for two cars
to pass but if there's a pedestrian in
the way they won't be able to pass and
there's no verge
for two large vans to go par
past one another and we do have the
extra large um hgvs
as well ashfield road itself is
is much busier than most c-class roads
and
it is used as a cut-through for all
types of vehicles from the a143 to the
a14
here we are proposing to build bungalows
which even the applicant suggests
might attract elderly people they are
probably less likely to want to walk for
over half an
hour to the shop and then carry their
shopping back home again
they will use a car and if they
subsequently become unable to drive they
will become isolated and rely heavily on
their neighbours
even so it would be encouraging less
relent on the motor vehicle for everyone
in paragraph 3.7 of the report the
officer claims that this development
offers strong
and direct support to the vitality of
the town
i'd like to point out that elmswall is
certainly not a town
and i think that two more bungalows will
provide insignificant benefits the
vitality of elmswell
given that we already have over 600 new
dwellings already got permission
and the draft jlp allocates over 800
dwellings
elmsworld is already a thriving
community and
if anything its facilities are already
growing to meet the demand
two more dwellings is neither here nor
there in the overall scheme of things
whilst it is pleasing to see that the
developer is proposing some rainwater
harvesting low carbon energy sources
and some biodiversity mitigation
the so-called benefits of this
development certainly do not
outweigh the dis benefits these do not
represent
the right homes in the right places so i
would urge you to refuse this
application
on both heritage grounds and
sustainability thank you
thank you very much counselor um right
any
uh questions you anyone wishes to pick
up
do you just want to comment on the
report as well yeah my apologies i've
just i've just spotted it and i do
apologize
you're quite right paragraph 3.7 page 10
i've got here uh says
age 26 in our papers okay sorry uh
viability of the town
state village i do apologize
unreservedly for that
uh mistake thank you okay
we have no questions so thank you
councilmember
okay so um members um
we now need to open up uh for debate uh
i'm happy that we just go by hands up
rather than going through
alphabetically because i think uh that
would give more
people come forward when they want to
speak rather than having to speak so
counselor eber and you're first off then
counselor pass more
thank you very much chair um did i just
ask john just to take the pic
the the screen down so that we we just
have members up now
thank you
thank you very much chair um i'm
very concerned about this um development
i i i can't see at all how it could be
classified as
a sustainable development it's well
outside
the village of elmswell and it's in an
area
of open countryside
along grove lane or walking or running
whatever long grove lane on a saturday
when the hdvs aren't operating you
just you're absolutely in the middle of
rural suffolk
um so i'm i've
have really struggled with the fact that
this is being classed as sustainable
development i
i do not think it is sustainable at all
um and i've been reading up on the nppf
and um you know whether our policies
hold for the sustainability and the nppf
says should avoid the development of
isolated homes in the countryside
unless a certain circumstance applies
and none of these apply
in this particular instance so and i
think the fact
that we've got if there's two homes
already there
um approved um so firstly i'd say it's
completely unsustainable secondly i
think it's a
over development of the site you've got
um
along grove lane there are only homes
actually
along grove lane there aren't any kind
of back from the lane
um in houses behind other houses as it
were
um so and that's the case all the way
along
um there's there's just the odd
farmhouse the odd
house here and there as you go down
grove lane
so secondly i'd say it's over
development of the site
and thirdly um i'm disappointed i
appreciate um
the planning officers comments about how
they pull a report together
but i'm very disappointed that there's
no heritage response
and i think that um even on heritage
grounds i mean we have we sit through
other planning applications where listed
buildings are 500 meters away and we're
told to consider them
within this application here we've got
one that's that's
opposite the curtail edge of it is
opposite the um
so i don't understand why we don't give
that
um you know decent weight and why there
isn't heritage response
so um i'm definitely not sitting on the
fence on this one chair i've got i would
say absolutely i would be
um voting in favor of refusal and basis
of
unsustainability over development of the
site and heritage grounds thank you very
much
thank you very much
uh thanks very much matthew uh i've
listened extremely carefully to all the
arguments from all sides and this is a
difficult um issue to make a decision on
however
having listened to that i i am on
balance
uh going to support the application and
what the officers say for the following
reasons
we are only talking about two additional
homes
and it does provide a benefit to the
local economy of course
from building and i think the conditions
and we're only talking about outline
planning permission here of course
um and of course the conditions put down
there recommended by the officers i do
think
provide sufficient mitigation looking at
biodiversity carbon footprints
and as i was always say how do we better
use scarce natural resources
and therefore i think on balance and i
would like to propose
uh approval of this other things i would
like to comment on this i'm
i i do understand the issue about access
and transport and so on
and i would if it's possible like to
make sure that the access to the site if
it's granted
is properly landscaped and i don't just
mean a few um
little stumps of hedges and so on a
proper mixed
um hedge uh like we have all over
farmland in suffolk that i know
particularly well
we do that and making sure that the
design details under the reserve matters
are extremely sympathetic
um to the neighboring properties and so
on because that is absolutely crucial
we do need more bungalows in mid-suffolk
and it's also the point that i think
we've got to be very careful if we're
suggesting that older people
um perhaps you question whether they
should live there
you know we do believe in freedom of
choice you know plenty of old people
who are even older than i am um who are
actually quite capable of driving cars
and so on
and with electrification of vehicles i
think that argument is perhaps not one
that i i would support that um
because we do need bungalows uh in
mid-suffolk
as regards the setting of a listed
building this i remember coming out when
i was on the planning committee before
it is a debatable point i do understand
the assertion made by
some of the um committee members but
again on balance
the listed building we're talking about
is some considerable distance away from
this application
and the fact that these uh two bungalows
would go behind
those uh buildings that have already
been given permission i think
sufficiently mitigates
um that for my um from my point of view
so the reasons for um go with the offer
the officer's recommendation i think we
do have to look
very sensibly at the implications of the
national
um planning framework policy planning
framework
decision i quite understand everybody
else's point of view
but as i say chairman in my view i would
like to propose
approval of this and it is a difficult
debate to have
so there you have it thank you thank you
very much
uh okay councillor muller uh thank you
chair
um i would like to second um councillor
passmore's um
recommendation for approval this
application uh we've had several
mentions about appeal decisions etc but
the position of msdc policies being able
to date
has been settled by a number of recent
appeal decisions within mid-suffolk
and the relevant appeal decisions are
material considerations
we should also consider the new anglia
strategic economic plan does acknowledge
that house building is a powerful
stimulus for growth
and supports around 1.5 jobs directly
and up to other additional jobs in the
wider community
i do i do believe also that there is a
shortage
of bungalow therefore i think
this is a good proposal i do not think
it will have much effect on the
actualistic building of grove farm
and therefore i'm happy to second uh
councillor pasmore's proposal thank you
thank you very much uh anyone else wish
to come in councilman
thank you chair um yeah i'm
i've grown increasingly uh unhappy with
this
application as we've heard more about it
and i think
for four reasons really all together
um the bungalow argument um
yes it would be it would be great to see
some but
i mean more bungalows in elmswell i've
seen to recall them fighting to get a
handful
on a big development right in the middle
of the village where they
where they would have been most
beneficial this is
not helpful they're in the wrong place
here
um i don't think we should follow the
poor precedent of the first two
um that they're not a good depression to
follow at all
um i've been quite concerned to hear
more about the heritage
argument um particularly the
the um the cartilage of
the grow farms actually right opposite
the entrance
to this um this development proposal
um thirdly this is something that used
to be called
backland development um
a phrase we haven't heard so much of
recently but
it is what it is what it is and um it
isn't characteristic of um
of grove lane which uh so i i know very
well having lived so close
and um but by the way for on the traffic
front i could just just mention
the the old phrase um about the
mr wilson's big lorries um what we're
talking about is abnormal loads
they are enormous they are very long
and um they they do take up the whole
the whole lane when they are
moving so just so everyone understands
what that's about
but i think the most important thing
ultimately
is that we should be looking for
biodiversity net
gain and to to lose
a piece of pasture which which has been
probably unimproved and never plowed
that is a very big biodiversity loss
and i can't see any significant gain
that's um that's here that could could
outweigh that
so i really cannot support
approval
thank you very much councillor mayor
thank you chair um for me
this is quite finely balanced there are
benefits
and there are impacts um but without
going over the points raised by um
previous councillors
to my mind the benefits do not
significantly and demonstrate out
perform the impacts so therefore i think
even though
it's a fine balance we should
find in favor of this development um a
point that um
council ebon raised about over
development
i can't support that if you look at um
the lane there are small groups of um
buildings houses
all the way down that lane and indeed
with the bungalows if they were built
it would balance quite nicely with the
um the heritage site the other side of
the road where you've got a small group
of buildings it's not individual
buildings down the road
so on balance even though i believe that
the
the benefits and the impacts are quite
evenly balanced um
there isn't that significant um
outweighing
so i i will be supporting um this
application
thank you very much councillor field
as people keep saying it's quite
balanced and once phil someone needs to
make a decision
or do i just kick this down the road to
the planning inspectorate
yet again um
and let's say one sums these things up
it tends to
if we're not careful just saying the
same things again
and the the heritage argument exists and
i was quite persuaded by the talk about
the
uh ancient green although it's not her
an undesignated
heritage asset as i understand it at the
moment so
perhaps we're exaggerating its status
somewhat
uh the farm is a substantial distance
away
whether it's the right sort of thinking
or not as i said here
my village has a number of heritage of
um
listed buildings in it there would be
nothing else if we kept a large
distance around every one of them
so there are issues there should we
be adopting an attitude that says um we
may only build on roads where there is a
pavement
there are many villages in suffolk
without
pavements should it just be that older
people like my good self should be
banned from such villages because of the
incredible danger we will experience if
we
walk along the village street and there
is a danger without a shadow of doubt
um so i don't find these things easy
to to to sum up really
is this an isolated house as someone
said if you
mppf it clearly says that
isolated houses in the countryside or
not
to be built but that in principle
you it is acceptable and in fact
encouraged to build to an extent in the
countryside
and i when i looked at the maps of this
i have a job
to believe that this location is
isolated
there are dwellings both sides of it as
we said there are two
bungalows intended in front of the site
um there are a lot of other uh
dwellings pretty close along along the
lane and certainly on the road into
elmswell
um should we really be proposing that
everything is totally unsustainable
i do i i do to an extent go along with
the comment that
uh council password made about the
thought that although
petrol and diesel cars are clearly not
acceptable
as we as we move forward into a
carbon-free world
it may well be that electric vehicles
[Music]
are so
difficult i shall decide as i put my
hand up no doubt or not
and so thank you bye
thank you council field so everyone has
spoken who
wants to speak does anyone else wish to
come in
nope okay so i'm going to go to the
chief planning officer to remind
the proposal of what's before us then
i'll ask the governance officer to
conduct a role call
with the proposer being councillor
passmore and the second accounts of
mother
for approval of the recommendations laid
out in our papers on page 34
page 35 is that correct john
so um yes so the recommendation here is
for outline planning permission
for two single story properties with
access
included and the recommendation is one
for
approval subject to conditions as
outlined by your papers
that's probably all i need to say okay
thank you uh councillor field did you
want to come back in
and councillor matheson i have your
hands up
no i'm on my old hand problem again no
from uh counselor madison
yeah can we just talk about the uh
conditions for a moment before we rush
to a decision
um the the swifts i think
bricks are are preferable to boxes
because they they will be
permanent and um
the in terms of the level access and so
on i think
what we're talking about is called an
accessible
standard um rather than a lower standard
so if we could use the correct phrasing
there and also i didn't really
understand the energy
energy and renewal integration i think
it's probably
at least a typo there and perhaps we
could um be
clear what we're roaming we'll just ask
you
to come in and clarify um in terms of
the swift
owl and probably the word back should be
there as well actually black boxes
i'm happy to change that to scheme uh in
the general sense uh because ultimately
reserve matters isn't before us
and uh we we can push that down the road
in terms of that conditions
so i'll i'll change boxes to uh our
swift and bat
scheme to be agreed uh respect
of energy and renewable um
then obviously you know this allows us
to seek
you know renewable energy ski elements
such as solar panels
air or heat pumps and so forth um to
come forward
for us to agree um i'm
i missed the third was there a third
point there as well
yes the the um there are three standards
of
accessibility for dwellings um and
um the level access
accessible access accessible standard i
think it's called
okay well as a council we've nev as a
councillor we've never
applied any access standards whatsoever
and i have started to introduce the idea
of at least having level access
uh available from the outside into the
property so
this is a relatively new thing that we
are starting to try and push forward as
a
a
commitment for developers to comply with
i personally
you know i've i've had design tours
where we've gone around modern housing
estates especially
where even though it's very flat land
there's still two steps up to the
front door uh totally unacceptable
really and with no reason to have that
so we
are now trying to make sure these level
acts there to enable wheelchair access
for all the runnings that's what that
condition is about
thank you thank you yeah i'm i was just
trying to to
point to a specific standard that is
available
and which i think we're going to
incorporate in future in jlp
thank you okay uh cancer field
yes point i forgot from my earlier
discussion
really um i think one of the
protesters did point out that this would
be more acceptable if it met a very high
environmental standard
and we seem to have a number of
conditions which might allow
us to apply higher standards i i would
certainly be happier as john actually
just said that if
we were ensuring there were
substantially higher standards
approaching the passive house type of
level
we're reluctant to propose a particular
possibly costly approval process but but
certainly
we need to move in that direction and
get very close to it
what i'll do john is that would be up to
the proposer and seconder but let me
just hear from ian de perez and then
from peyton g because both have their
hands up just very briefly chairman i
could have waited a couple of minutes
possibly but i'll
um for the i mean we everyone in the
meeting knows this i think but for the
benefits of anyone watching this on
on youtube live stream to confirm the
cat this council's usual process is that
mid-suffolk district council has a rule
that the ward members may speak but not
vote this is an eight-member committee
councillor sarah mansell is a member of
the committee but
she i think if we're in the council
chamber should be sitting on the
opposite side of this yeah
we will go through that when we come to
the royal call the though you that
that's just
make sure that's understood that's all i
needed thank you thank you
john payment
is there anything further you wish to
add about the conditions
in respect to the kitchen i don't think
there's anything much further i should
add but if you are
moving into changing the proposal to say
this is a passive house
which is a far higher uh a different
designed spec
um i'm that is not before us
um and i would you know that's what i
would try to say though
okay uh so uh tim passmore uh
and dave muller councillor muller and
pasmore obviously
we've made a few changes there to the
recommendation that have been suggested
uh regarding swift our backed schemes to
be agreed
we're leaving the level access because
that's been explained to us what that's
around
um is there anything else you want to
change in the conditions before we go to
a vote are you happy as they stand
um thanks matthew well yeah i am happy
with that as i stand but i do take um
john field's point
it is about as i said earlier about um
trying to make better scarce net
resources i wouldn't go so far as to an
absolute eco house
but i hope that the officers whilst we
can't necessarily condition it to every
single word
do take full account of making best use
of scarce next resources which includes
reduction of carbon footprint grey water
schemes harvesting rain
etc so the spirit of it is i know you
can't condition it specifically i'm well
aware of that
but i absolutely agree with what john
john said there so as long as the office
is taken into account
i'm happy to leave it as it is okay and
the same same with you
yes yes i'm happy to leave it thank you
so on that basis we'll now go to a vote
can i ask the governance officer to
conduct the role call please
thank you chair so um just as mr duprey
was has
laid out um in the in his previous point
earlier
um counselor mansell as the board member
cannot vote
on the application so if i if you could
please respond with for
against or abstain so counselor rachel
ebern
against
oh no my pen has decided to give up the
ghost
it would as apologies chair right um
technology we have
mr duprez who's with us and can keep a
record
yes chairman i'll i'm counting as well
so don't worry okay thank you
um councillor field
no sorry counselor did i could i just
confirm again sorry
so against
i said thank you thank you sorry
councillor um councillor field
for councillor hicks
or councillor matheson
against councillor mayor
four councillor muller
four and council pass more
four thank you chair i make that
five votes to two and carried
and yes chair i agree five votes
five votes to two carried okay thank you
very much everyone
so the next item uh is the land staff of
south of fox hollow the street wives and
what i
propose is we will say we should have a
break every 19 minutes
so we'll start again at 10 minutes past
11 please
we have a 10 minute
thanks everyone and welcome back uh to
the second uh
part of the mid-south district council
uh development control committee a
meeting
uh just to make sure that everyone has
returned uh could i ask if we could just
do a role called
with the governance officer just check
everyone is now present
thank you chair so
let's get the list up here so we have so
if you could just
let me know if you're back is counselor
ebern
present councillor field
president councillor mayor
present and councillor mellon who is
attending as the ward member
present thank you chair we're all here
thanks
great thank you very much so now move on
to dc 20 03 244
land south of fox hollow the street
wiveston uh and
i hand over to the case officer alex
scott to introduce the application
please sorry matthew before you move on
rick speaking counselor i've just noted
during the break that john stebbing is
the architect for this uh development
um i'd like to declare that i know john
stephen he lives in my ward
okay thank you so that's a non-pecuniary
interest um yes chairman that's a that's
a non-peculiar interest
um julie noted as such thank you
thanks thanks very much over to uh alex
scott to introduce
uh thank you chairman um if i can just
try and share my screen
and put the presentation up
let's correct one and we'll go to the
slideshow
everybody can see that here we are
right okay um right so this is uh
application reference dc
oblique 20 oblique 03244
lands south of fox hollow the street in
wyverstone
the application is submitted under
section 73
of the town and country planning act to
vary
the approved plans and documents of an
existing planning permission
reference dc oblique 20 oblique 0
20 22 which was
granted for the erection of
one single story dwelling and detached
garage
and construction of a new vehicular
access this was granted under
delegated authority authority delegated
to
uh the chief planning officer in july of
this year
so this application is to
to vary that existing that existing
permission
the proposed amendments proposed to move
the approved dwelling further back
into the site by approximately 14 meters
to move the location of the garage
back by approximately 15.6 meters
to extend the garage by approximately
one meter in width
and with some minor external window and
door alterations to the east elevation
of
the garage the application does not
propose
any alterations to the approved scale
and design of the dwelling
just its location and the approved
access
is also not proposed to be altered by
way of this
current section 73 application
now the application has been reported to
development
uh committee by the ward member and
for the reasons as set out in your in
your papers
so remove to the to the presentation
itself
and for the avoidance of doubt this is
the location of wyverstone
within the district
this is the general location of the site
within the immediate area at wyverstone
street
is the site location plan as submitted
with the application proposal
the site which is edged in red here
extends to 0.274
of a hectare it sits to the rear
of the properties of fox hollow and
field
haven to the north
and this slide shows you the planning
constraints
which affect the site and area and the
green lines
indicate the settlement boundaries
as defined in the current local plan
the colored buildings as you can see
here in orange
uh some in red are listed
buildings the avenue
of trees to the uh to the lane and in
front of the site
is protected by a tree preservation
order
and this blue area off to the east of a
site
represents the environment agency flood
zones
flood zones two and three
excuse me uh this is uh an aerial view
of the of the wider area
and we have a uh a more close-up
uh aerial view of the the site which
again is edged in red here
um points of reference uh
this existing building to the south is
an agricultural
shed also within the the applicant's
ownership
and this existing bund in the center
with with trees
is proposed to be removed and has been
approved to be removed by way of the
existing
permission which the applicant is
proposing to alter by where this section
73
application this is a site
layout as proposed and
in the comparison for you on the left
of your screen this is the layout as
already
approved by the host planning and on the
right
is what is currently proposed so the
proposed dwelling is moved back into
sight
um by a further 14 meters
and um it is a little bit closer to the
neighboring boundary by about 0.2 of a
meter that's that's 20 centimeters
and the garage again is proposed to be
moved back
by 15.6 meters
and it would line up with the
the front of the existing shed to the
south and
uh adjacent to this uh building in the
on the neighbours property
um presumed to be an outbuilding but um
uh perhaps um the the neighbor or the
um the objector could uh confirm that
because
um not having the opportunity to go into
the neighbor's property it wasn't that
clear from my site visit i must say
so perhaps they could clarify that thank
you
um and
yes the the the outbuilding would be uh
0.7 of a meter closer to the
to the boundary um that's 70 centimeters
and the proposed access is uh staying as
is
and there is some uh some alterations to
the uh to the driveway
and uh parking arrangements um as you
can see there as well
this is the proposed plans of the
dwelling
and as i mentioned before these are not
proposed to change
under the current application just where
it would be
on the site as you can see this is a
four bedroom bungalow and
for reference the maximum ridge height
would be six meters
this is the garage as uh currently
proposed
and then for uh comparison again uh on
the
left is what uh has already been
approved
by where the host application and on the
right is what
has been it is currently uh proposed
the proposed building um would be
one meter wider that's currently
proposed
and it is proposed to
put a a gym um for domestic use
uh within the uh within the building and
the
ancillary shower room uh in lieu of the
the stores
which were previously approved and there
are some
minor alterations to the uh doors and
windows to the east elevation which
looks away from the highway into the
into the site
and this is the proposed access to the
site
uh the existing access will be uh
stopped up and uh this has already been
uh approved by way of the host uh
planning permission and is not
proposed to be uh altered at all by
where the the
the current application on to some
photographs for you this is the
existing site access
this just shows the relationship with
the
existing dwellings so at the bottom of
the
the rear gardens of the existing
properties
and this is taken
from the access looking into the site
and for reference the proposed garage
would be
in approximately this location
uh with the proposed dwelling sitting
behind this bundling but
that bonding as mentioned before will
be removed and has been approved to be
removed by way of the
previous application and this is the
existing agricultural shed
to the south of the proposal site but uh
within the
applicant's ownership as shown within
the blue line
on the site location plan and finally we
have a
view of the street scene back up from
the site frontage towards
the uh street and this is the adjacent
dwelling at fox hollow
just off to the right here that
concludes the presentation
uh officer's recommendation as set out
in the papers is for
approval thank you thank you can you
just go back to the
uh put up a picture of the two proposals
the
the before and after because i think
we just have a have that up that might
be used indeed
councilor matheson you wanted to come in
yeah what was the
purpose of the bonding did that have
some particular landscaping
function in terms of screening something
else that's being lost
i'm not aware of why that was originally
planted uh councilman matheson um
yes that that's not clear that's wrong
you can ask we can maybe
unfold later yeah absolutely but are you
saying it's
got permission to go from the first
application
uh yes as you can see the uh approved
layout already here on the uh
the left of you you're not seeing your
oh right there yet
so it's removed anyway okay we'll stop
worrying about that one then
okay uh alex could you put up that
picture before and after
um i'm sorry are you not getting that
it's showing on my screen
um i'm trying to see what's going on
with the channel
we'll keep going uh councilman
uh thank you chair uh i've got a number
of questions and i'm not sure if they're
all
actually relevant so do tell me if i'm
not meant to be asking such questions
um first of my first question is about
the band of uh
protected trees uh now whilst i
understand the access has already got
permission
do any of those trees have to come down
for the access
that's my first question uh second
question
is um there's a power line across the
site
um and i'm not sure where that is in
relation to where the new dwelling is
going to go and whether it's in the way
or whether the wires are in the way
so can you explain that and my third
question
was about the consultation from place
services
which is on pages 73 to 75
of our papers where there are a number
of
conditions or strategies that have been
proposed and they don't appear
in the permission that's already been
granted for the
fur the house has already got permission
and i wondered if they were likely to
why they weren't in that permission and
can we put them into this one
if necessary okay thanks very much i
think they're all
questions absolutely so over to you uh
alex please
okay um now the the first question which
i believe was um
the um any further detected
exactly yes indeed um well the answer to
that
is uh no nothing further than what has
already been uh approved
and um you're uh your tree officer your
arboricultural officer i'll just get
that right
um has been um consulted has raised no
objection subject to condition
um which was imposed on the host and is
proposed to be repeated um by where this
section 73 application
the existing access is proposed to be
replanted so what we what we lose we
we gain in this location
over here um in terms of
power lines yes yeah i was just trying
to pick that up on uh
one of the photographs i uh i had i
believe there's um
the start of it here and it would
go along the um the sites um
yeah when i was on site i didn't believe
it was directly
um above the proposed garage building it
would be uh quite close but
not directly above it therefore i didn't
think there was any
particular conflict um although that
would be a
discussion with the utilities companies
about the the distance away
a building had to be to to power lines
i'm not i'm not aware of that
but um for planning um
i think there's a significant uh impact
there
and um the point from place services
point from place services uh yes indeed
um
now that this is a section 73
application
um to um very condition two
only um uh could may i just uh
ask the uh the chief officer um
view on adding additional conditions
which haven't already been
um imposed by a weather host application
because that wasn't picked up at
the host application uh john are you
able to
yeah i i was you're getting in
okay i was trying to i thought this
might come up and i'm trying to think
of a easy way to summarize this so
what we've got before is it's called a
section 73 but it's an old-fashioned
term for effectively saying this is a
minor amendment
application so we have the main
application already granted
the principle the layout everything else
all
packaged up already this is seeking to
only change one element of that
and the element is trying to change is
the approved plans
now if we
uh if the change in the plans means that
we can associate a
further condition to that specific
change
then we can probably get away with
adding further conditions
but in this case what we're dealing with
is a movement of the building back
and the movement of the garage back i
would find it difficult to see how i
would then associate
the principle of the development in
terms of the biodiversity net gain
to the fact that the building has just
moved back and i think that would be
unreasonable to
impose a further condition in that
context now if i had to
because of the movement of the building
back and i had to impose a further
condition
in respect of a particular window
because by moving the building back
the window would start to overlook or
have a different effect
on amenity and we could solve that by
putting a further condition on
then yes that would be reasonable and
probably a lawful approach to
to this particular way forward but when
you start getting to other grounds
such as uh you know why was not
renewable energies
imposed on this site before why was that
you you're going to have asked yourself
how can i justify that against what this
proposal actually is
um and um that would be difficult
it is not impossible to do it but it is
not recommended and
it is a subject possibly that you get
done for costs for
appeal if it is deemed to be
unreasonable behavior
thank you very much thank you could i
just
well firstly um i'd like to thank um the
explanation about the
conditions um but i just like to come
back on the power cable
uh because as i said uh earlier on i did
go and have a look at the site
and i uh the photo that um
is on our presentation is is not quite
such a wide angle as the one i took
myself
and there is another the the wires go to
another pole
further back on the side and i i it's
very hard to judge the depth of field
but it looks to me
like the house is going to be under the
paralysis
can i suggest let's raise that with the
applicant
okay thank you yeah councillor
thanks matthew just really following on
from um
john pate mcgee's comments and i don't
know whether he or alex would like to
answer
could you just remind me i know we're
moving the proposal to move the site
um backwards how far away would it be
from
the neighboring properties in the for
the
now and then if we agree the uh
amendment
how far away would it be i know we're
moving it back uh what is it the um
certain number of me 14 meters but how
does that affect the distance of
neighboring property and
the uh comment about visual immunity
effects on that potential
effects on that please
um well i'll ask answer that if i may
yeah
um yes it would be the current proposal
would be 36 meters as i measure it
uh from the rear of the uh nearest
existing uh
neighboring property which is field
haven
and that would be um uh 0.2 of the meter
which is 20 centimeters
closer yeah okay yeah
and on the visual amenity could you just
comment what your assessment of that
would be
does it affect it or not really well um
yes i said in my report um i
i didn't think so as um case officer
that's my assessment it's a single story
dwelling um
you have a distance to the existing
boundary and then a significant distance
to the um
to the dwelling as well yes it may
impinge on a view slightly but
uh no significant impact on existing
residential immunity
was my assessment that's helpful perfect
thank you very much
thank you very much um we may not have
the applicant
speaking i'm i'm informed but we'll get
to that
as councilman so we'll come back to on
that we'll just see
see where we are and if you need to
raise it further uh before we go into
debate we can do that
if that's okay uh councillor field
thank you we've just heard how
far the dwelling would be from adjacent
properties
i i note it seems to be being moved
because of the distance from it
to the um shed which or barn that the
applicant owns i wonder what that is as
a comparable distance but
presumably that's being done for amenity
reasons
um and uh
are we arguing that that immediacy is
one that needs to be um
improved and the one of the existing
neighbours is one that isn't
significantly impacted
what is it what is the distance between
the um
right well i've got a scale
yes i make it approximately 20 meters
between the existing barn and the
proposed welling
so so so a bit under two to one
difference okay
okay uh counselor manso is that an old
hand
i've taken it away now yeah no problem
thank you um
okay uh we don't have any other
questions at this point
uh so we'll now move on um
and now like we don't have anyone from
the parish council to speak
today that's joined us but we do have an
objector mr glenn horn mr glen hall if
you'd like to turn on your camera and
your microphone please
and you have three minutes to address
the committee uh thank you chairman uh
can i just make it clear i'm speaking on
behalf
of mr mrs bentley who are the residents
of fieldhaven
and council field has just summed it up
exactly right
the proposal moves the new building from
behind fox hollow
to behind field paving their house and
the concern is that a six meter high
even if it is a bundle building does
have a significant impact on their
immunity
the justification for the move is to
improve the view
for the new residents of this property
um there is a principle in planning that
no one is entitled to a view
mr mrs bentley fully appreciate this
although this being the case
how could it be that residents of a new
building
should have a greater entitlement than
existing residents
the proposed new location does have a
negative impact
uh on the nearest neighbours because it
does impact on their outlook
and potentially the privacy certainly in
that garden
which are material considerations as
this
proposed site is now directly aligned
with the rear of their property
we're simply asking the principal to be
applied evenly
miss suffolk planning policy seeks not
to cause harm to existing communities
or residents so on balance the
consideration must be tilted in favor
of the current residents rather than
towards a new build
another consideration is that by moving
this building across even
further it could have been placed
directly behind the applicant's
existing residential property the laws
we've not seen any justification as to
why this hasn't been proposed because
that would probably be more suitable
unfortunately the reason of assumption
is that by going here
it would negatively impact on the loans
in very much the same way and would
therefore be undesirable
it would also potentially reduce the
number of available plots across the
rest of the sites
lending weights to our concerns
regarding the
potential for future development so
quite simply the original location
is at the entrance to the site and as
such would restrict
access to the rest of the site and
therefore in itself reduced potential
for further development it's also
shielded from you
viewed by the existing outbuilding at
the end of the garden of fox hollow
unfortunately the removal of condition
too allowing this building to be being
to the proposed new location could
clearly lead to the over development of
the whole site
and the original granted permission
identifies the potential over
development of the site as a risk
and has two conditions specifically in
place to address this risk
conditions 14 and 15 are in place in
order to avoid cumulative development
that will be detrimental to amenity
and contrary to policy the summary is
that we ask
committee to consider how they would
view an application which had the
potential
to deliver uncontrolled significant
growth if it were brought forward in
their own awards
to ensure the principle of entitlement
to a view be evenly applied
and to ensure that the existing
conditions which are in place
simply be maintained and fully enforced
they are a balanced and rational
approach
which effectively address the the uh
resident's concerns
uh and there's been no good case made
for the conditions to be removed and
also
thank you thank you very much okay
um do we have any questions may i pick
up a
yes point if i may just talk questions
um
just in respect of the mention of
conditions 14 and 15
um this is a variation of only one
condition which is condition two
all other conditions within the host
application
would be remain in effect uh this is
also not the removal of condition two
that is the variation
of it by obviously changing the approved
plans
um and i just want to be clear
on on that um the other thing i would
say is that the
host application if you like has a
pacific red plan
uh the land behind the laurels i think
it was is outside of that redline plan
so this application can't be very to go
beyond the red line that's already been
approved
that would be a different application
that would be a fresh application in its
entirety
thank you so we can only look at what's
before us today thank you
okay um do we have any questions uh
councillor muller
yeah uh thank you uh mr horn could you
could you just
clarify what the building is on the fox
hollow site directly behind the proposed
site of the garage
it's a garden out building it says it's
just a garden out building yes
yes thank you very much thank you chair
thank you councillor mayor
um mr horn can you confirm field haven
that is a bungalow is it
uh yes this thank you
okay any other questions okay thank you
very much for joining us today
um we now move on uh we don't have a
supporter
so i'll ask the applicant to speak uh if
they've joined us
uh robert has the applicant joined us
today
sorry chair thank you for um the
applicant didn't ask to speak at the
committee today um
it was in your order of proceedings but
in anticipation but they
i have not heard anything from the
applicant okay
thank you so we now go straight on to
the ward member then council
andrew mellon uh to address the
committee
councillor mellon over to you uh good
morning chair and good morning committee
members
uh members will have seen that uh this
application is before you this morning
because of a call-in that i
instigated and i should state that we've
seen is my home village
um although i live at the other end of
the village to the application
site and i think it's useful for
counselors to know that there is a
a longer planning history than has
appeared in the papers
um in terms of the wider area
and that the applicant owns the first
application that came in was
dc 1802122 applying for a change of use
of an agricultural building
to a dwelling house this is the metal
clad barn which you saw
in the presentation this application
application was refused uh it was taken
to appeal
and was also turned down on appeal we
then had the outline application
for one detached dwelling dc 1903 846
which has appeared
which was approved in october 2019
and this was then followed by full
application
dc 2002
which you have in the bundle of papers
and that was approved only in july
this year and now we have the
application before us which i have
called in
now i realized that this may seem to
members that the current application is
a minor change
to that or already granted the bungalow
is shunted back in the site
and the garage is made larger
however as i have set out this
application is part of a series of
applications
in the area and i believe this one has
the greatest impact on the residential
amenity of
neighbouring properties on page 90 of
the papers
the second paragraph sets out our policy
that development should not
materially or detrimentally affect the
amenities of the occupiers of it
neighboring properties
um this is in the office's report for
the existing permission
for the front of the site which then
goes on to state that there were no
concerns with that application
but i would like to argue that with this
application
the proposed bungalow will cause
detriment to the residents of fieldhaven
as it is now nearer to them uh really at
the end of their garden
and they have hitherto enjoyed a rural
outlook from their house and garden
and this would be largely lost they
would not be losing just a view it'd be
much more than that
the application site sits at a slightly
higher elevation
than the garden of fieldhaven so there's
concern about overlooking
my other concern is that pushing the
development back in the site opens up
essentially
a new sector of development into
agricultural land
bordering the village we have an
existing permission close to the road
frontage
and this is accepted if built out as
agreed
only back in july it would form part of
a
an intermittent line of development down
the lane which is known locally as
ketchus lane
so this development includes the
existing metal barn
which i referred to earlier as well as
other buildings and homes a few hundred
yards further down the lane
but what we're considering today pushes
development back into the agricultural
hinterland behind this line of
development
as i see it although a minor change it
would be a significant
and worrying extension to the settlement
envelope
now i'm not opposed to development in
the village wyverson has had
several permissions granted including
one for two homes
uh this granted this week which i
supported
but we have an existing permission which
everyone is happy with
granted only three months ago and
bearing in mind the pattern of
applications
this new one is a step too far the
applicant states that the reason for the
proposed amendment is to improve
their view but this can only happen by
by causing a significant detriment to
others so can i urge committee members
to reject this application
leaving the applicant to build out his
existing permission which is agreed by
all to be a better result
thank you
thanks very much councilman um okay do
we have any questions for the ward
member
right we have no hands up okay thank you
very much
um okay so it's now up to us uh to just
council mellon i tell you you might be
able to answer one question about the
power lines uh as the applicant isn't
here
can you give any insight into the where
the power lines are on the site
uh i'm afraid i can't share sorry i have
no information on that
oprah thanks very much i may be able to
help if you would like me to
i appreciate this is google street view
um
and i don't know how old specifically
this uh
is but if i just quickly share this it
shows
the power line i think that's what we're
talking about uh bear with me
okay thank you
you hit a button and nothing happens
that's always good isn't it try again
here we go
so if i share the street view
right so i'm on the
uh the road frontage and
that appears to me to be possibly the
power line that is going across
in part the site and this is the site
and the site goes behind those trees um
i would say that that power line would
be affected by both the
proposal that's been approved and the
proposal before you
in some way or another and it might be a
private matter for the
developer of the site to have to deal
with the utilities
uh an alteration to that power line or
not
but that would be there for their
authority to decide does that help
yeah that's we're not going to get
better than that so thank you and i
think your point is
valid that i mean we can all see it goes
across the previous
and the proposed uh application
so it'll be up to us to weigh that in
thank you very much for sharing that
okay please bear that with the mind that
it's a google street view image and yeah
yeah and it could be it could be out of
date but uh
we could see those wires um in some of
the
photos that were taken by alex scott as
well okay so members
council master do you have a question or
did you want to come in to be the first
in the debate
i i wanted to come back on the power
lines actually
uh because i've subsequently since asked
my question i have looked at google
aerial view
and you can actually see if you blow it
up enough you can see where the
the one at the back of the site is and
if i'd sort of roughly draw a straight
line between that
pylon if you like to say and the one in
the back of the garden of the
house just to the north i would say that
the new
position of the dwelling is
more under the lines than the existing
one but
as you say it presumably is just a
private matter
for the applicant to deal with but i
think it is an issue
but it's obviously not a planning issue
maybe
that's uncorrected otherwise it's an
issue for the applicant
subject to them getting permission or
the existing permission rather than
something that's
something the committee needs to take
into account is that correct
it is correct it would be um for the uh
applicant to deal with with with the
utility in question
uh in order to resolve any particular
conflict there may be that you know
that that's that's a private matter
between those two parties it wouldn't be
redeemed to be a planning consideration
in my
opinion to give much weight thank you
counselor field is there a question
you have at this stage or do you want to
go into debate i was just going to
comment them presumably it would also
involve their health and safety
executive because
those wires are not exactly uh person
friendly
yeah yeah okay so members we've had all
the information put before us it's now
up to us to make a proposal
uh and to debate uh the application
before us
uh so open it up to members uh whoever
wants to come in
council mathesons first off
yes thank you with with um councillor
mansell's
points about um biodiversity enhancement
um i i had that down
to raise at this later stage um
it is it is very disappointing that the
original
permission did not
take up the place services who said that
they had
no objection subject to securing
ecological mitigation and
enhancement measures page 73 to 76
of the papers so
if if we if we're minded to
approve this and i'm not convinced that
we should at the moment
um i hope that mr scott mr payton
g will strain every sinew to find
ways of bringing those recommendations
back into the conditions thank you
thank you uh council manson councillor
field
uh thank you chair um now
i am i i i'm seriously disappointed
actually that the previous
application was granted permission with
or without
the biodiversity conditions
and i am really struggling to see why
this new application
is is presenting more harm than the one
that's already got permission
okay so the other one was at the end of
of the garden of um whatever it's called
um fox hollow um
and this one is at the end of the garden
of fairhaven
so it's a different resident who's
objecting to having a house behind their
back garden
um and okay it's not fair on the
residents of the fairhaven
but maybe the first one wasn't fair on
the residents of fox hollow
um i'm struggling to see why it's any
worse
than the original um i personally i
think
this is not the right place to put a
house in the first place it's quite
clearly
beyond the edge of the gardens which
sort of form a linear pattern
along the wyverstone street so
at the moment much as i don't like it
and i really wish we could put those
biodiversity conditions back in as as
councillor matheson has already
mentioned but i am really struggling as
to why this application
is any worse than the one that's already
got permission but i just wish
that hadn't got permission but it has we
are where we are and i i'd love to hear
other people's views on why this is
worse than the one that's already got
permission
thank you thank you thank you very much
councillor field
okay i feel i think it's worse than the
one that has a
permission for a couple of reasons it
does impact on the
amenity of a as you say of a different
property in fact
it impacts on the immediacy of two
properties
where it used to be one which seems to
be
somewhat more detrimental i do think
there's an issue
about it opening up the possibility of
further developments
on this site and obviously we shouldn't
indulge in imagination
and decisions on on that basis
so i would stick with the reason that i
would advocate that we do not approve
this
is because it impacts the amenity of
existing
residents to improve the amenity of the
applicant for the new property um
and you know
[Music]
he or she or wherever the applicant
decided
to build to apply for a house in the
position that is
currently approved and was obviously
fully aware of the
uh issues surrounding that at that time
so my view is and taking the point that
perhaps we could debate the
the the sense of development in this
position
that this area at all but that has been
done
there is an existing uh approval
which is only two or three months ago so
my view is
we should reject this we should stick
with the current
layout because of the impact on the
amenity of the properties at uh
field haven um and uh
that that that's that's where we should
remain
i do think the impact on the power lines
is another issue it's probably not as we
say a planning issue but
clearly um they would
they would they transit the site they
would undoubtedly be closer to the house
in its new position
and there are a number of uh issues
result around that including the the
possibility if you had to move those
lines lift their height or whatever it
is it would be
um a problem to the everyone supplied by
that
route and indeed there are
the views of many that there are
problems if you
build dwellings too close to powerlines
so that's something that should be
discovered but i would recognize that
those are not
planning issues but so that we should
take give
us high weight it's the immunity issue
that concerns me
thank you thank you thank you very much
counselor
um thank you matthew well um
interestingly this is another
tricky one and i was initially minded to
think well why do we need to change
anything at all but having listened to
the arguments
um actually i don't entirely agree with
my good friend john
john field and this hence my question
earlier regarding the distance from
other properties so i can't see that it
makes
a great deal of difference so i'm not
sure there's a rational reason
given that we're only asked to look at
this variation the condition we've got
to stick to what we're asked to look at
and what we have to do
so i am happy to propose that we do
grant permission
the other thing i just this is a bit of
a question actually if i may
share on the recommendations on page 60
of our report it does
talk about the removal of permitted
development rights and i do think that's
important because
i think there is a degree of nervousness
amongst all of us if you move a site
back well then you stick another
couple of houses in front but i'm
assuming that the removal of permitted
development rights would mean that
couldn't happen unless you
sought to permission and make it much
more difficult so that reassures me
and whilst we can't impose this as a
condition then i absolutely agree with
everybody else's comments regarding
biodiversity and and i would also
say well perhaps uh to the planning uh
officers
do everything you can to work with the
applicant should permission be granted
to make sure that those concerns
are properly addressed and not just a
sort of token
well here's a bat box and that'll do so
um i think that's a very important point
but i accept we can't
add that as a condition because we're
looking at one thing so i'm actually
formally
proposing an approval of this with those
other caveats
thank you very much councillor mayor
thank you um does this affect
the amenities of two houses more than
the original
fox hollow is two-story field haven is a
bungalow so i think he could make a case
that by moving it back
fox hollow's um views are improved
uh and field haven how much would it be
affected um
there's a large hedge between hedges can
be removed
so i'm not sure that um we can make a
case for
um the amenities being um reduced
i do struggle with moving it at all i
look at the plans and
to my mind the the original position is
a far better position
having visited the site um
[Music]
it's very flat how much would the view
be improved so
whilst my personal opinion would be to
remain with the original one
i can't i can't see a reason for
refusing
um the application so i think
on that basis i'm happy to second the
proposal that's been put forward
thank you very much okay i don't have
any
other hands up i mean i'll just add my
thoughts i mean again
um the immunity issue is a really
difficult one because
you're moving it from one to another uh
of course to the
to the uh resident that's being
represented by mr horn
to them this this will be uh you know be
something they don't want seen it's a
that's they're going to feel some of the
impact
versus other people are going to get
less impact but you know for
us in terms of the wider
impact of the immunity i think actually
you know there is a good distance
between the two
um although i do understand the the you
know the residence concerns but i'm not
sure that's a strong enough reason for
for refusing this and the point that
councilman mellon makes i absolutely
agree of course
um when one looks at planning
applications one always considers about
what this may
impact and what what could come forward
after it but i'm afraid today
we can only look at what is before us
and the application before us and not
uh not the wider you know that this may
lead to other applications that's really
not what's before a state because the
first day
is just what's in the papers and that is
all we can consider
so while i can see the frustrations of
the neighbor and understand councillor
melissa's concerns
um i can't really find any reason uh as
to why i would be able to refuse
uh this application so my views i will
support it but i can see
the reasons why people are concerned uh
oh councilman so your hands come up
uh if i'm allowed to come back um thank
you chair
um uh i'd just like to i mean i for once
actually council hicks i i actually
probably agree with you maybe that's a
surprise but
um i'd just like to come back on the on
the
aspect that mention of cumulative
development that has been picked up
i personally don't see that this new
layout
makes it any more likely than before the
the blue line ownership is the whole of
that field
they could come back and ask to knock
the
metal shed down or whatever it is and
put five more houses in there
they could have done that before i don't
think that actually makes any difference
and and i agree that you know we can't
we can't look to the future
and and as i've said before i really
can't see why this is any worse than the
other one i don't like it i didn't like
the other one but it's no worse really
thank you okay we have councillor field
then i think we'll go to the vote
councillor field thank you for letting
me return for a second
i was just going to point out unless the
officer tells us otherwise
i don't think removal of permitted
development rights
impacts on potential further housing
development
it would prevent people shifting windows
in houses or
putting out buildings but it's nothing
else of substantial
weight yeah that's correct uh john do
you just want to clarify that or alex
just clarify
permit development right is about
outbuildings and further extending of
the house isn't it rather than a new
house coming in
uh yes uh luckily uh a new house still
needs planning permission of some sort
uh so
you know in all respect that would
require a separate application in any
event yeah
exactly okay thank you okay so we have
no other speakers we've had it proposed
by councillor passmore and seconded by
councillor mayor
so i'll now uh for the recommendation as
laid out on page 59
uh and uh 60 of our papers but i'll just
hand over to the chief planning officer
just to confirm the proposal
and then ask the governance officer to
conduct a role call
yes i i can confirm that essentially
what we are here
doing is varying condition two so
updating the plan details
to accord to the layout presented to
members
and all other conditions would remain in
effect and therefore we would be
issuing a an application on that basis
thank you
hello yeah thank you so
now i'll carry out the royal court
please thank you chair
so if members could please respond as
usual with fought against or abstain
so councillor rachel even
for cancer john field
against council matthew hicks
four councillor sarah mansell
four councillor john matherson
against cancer richard mayer
four counselor dave muller
four and catch the tim passmore
cool thank you chair i make that six
votes to two
so the motion's carried can i just
confirm with mr duprey i agree six votes
is the motion carried
thank you okay thank you very much um do
we have any site inspection requests
that need to be reported to the
committee please
no chair nope okay so i now formally
close the meeting
at 12 o'clock thanks everyone for
joining us
and we close the meeting
you